ça le premier film qui vient entre 5000
et 10000 en parler dans le monde avec un
petit consensus autour de 7000 mais en
france il ya deux personnes sur trois
qu'il ne parle qu'une seule langue le
français
alors voici les trois meilleurs
raccourci à utiliser pour apprendre très
vite une langue à l'oral avec en bonus
un maximum d'infos insolites sur les
langues que j'ai découvert pendant mes
recherches par exemple xavier est ce que
tu sais pourquoi on retrouve dans toutes
les langues les consonnes ppm dans les
mots qui désignent le père et la mère
mais c'est ça et bien tout à l'heure tu
seras le whif généraux
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il existe de nombreuses
manières pour apprendre une langue et
bien souvent c'est d'abord à l'école
qu'on ait initié mais après c'est à nous
poursuivre pour fixer le tout est
pratiqué régulièrement et ça c'est pas
simple heureusement il existe depuis
plusieurs années des solutions très
simples comme le propose le sponsor de
cette vidéo babel si vous connaissez pas
à babel c'est un service d'apprentissage
des langues où l'humain est tout
simplement au coeur de la démarche pour
résumer babel a recours à de vrais
professeurs de langues pour créer les
leçons que vous aller étudier à travers
l'application mais aussi à travers des
cours en ligne en direct et même des
podcasts en tout ces quatorze longues
que vous pouvez apprendre avec babel
évidemment c'est pour tous les niveaux
et c'est notamment top pour commencer à
connaître le vocabulaire utile et
pratique dans la vie de tous les jours
qui vous permettra d'avoir des échanges
très rapidement dans la langue de votre
choix aux quatre coins du monde c'est ça
qu'on veut par exemple si demain je
décide de prendre la résolution
d'apprendre une nouvelle langue je sais
déjà dernier l'outil j'aime tourner si
l'appli vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
passer par le lien description par ce
qui vous permet de bénéficier d'une
réduction spéciale de 30 % pour six mois
12 mois ou même pour un accès à vis à
babel
parlons maintenant de la première des
trois astuces de cette vidéo alors ok en
france on est grave à bourg de la
maîtrise des langues et on a souvent
l'impression que ça va être une galère
sans nom de s'y mettre vous savez quoi
baysse allait quand même un peu parce
qu'en général on reproduit le même
apprentissage qu'on a eu à l'école oral
et écrit en même temps c'est un tag
grammaire vocabulaire conjugaison etc
c'est un plaisir quoi c'est un gros
délire et en plus vous avez remarqué que
dans les cours de 30 élèves en on passe
son temps à écouter des personnes qui
ont un mauvais accent comme nous et qui
font des fautes comme nous ça c'est pas
ou pour notre oreille notre cerveau la
première des astuces qui fonctionne bien
s'est trouvé une vraie motivation avant
même de commencer si c'est juste
apprendre une langue au cas où ces morts
vous allez procrastiner vous allez
trouver des excuses puis essayer
d'éviter la dissonance cognitive pour
encore culpabiliser parce que vous
n'avez pas tenu donc d'abord vous devez
trouver l'angle la bonne motivation le
truc qui vous stimule de cibles
commençaient l'espagnol demain vous
pouvez peut-être loin d'un appartement
dix jours en espagne pendant six mois à
partir de ce moment là vous avez six
mois pour tenir une conversation de base
en espagnol et allait manger des paellas
avec vos nouveaux potes locaux tout à
l'heure je vous donnerai la première
motivation que j'ai pu voir ça a bien
marché une par contre quand on analyse
le vocabulaire basiques de 6000 langues
on voit que 62% des mots ont des
sonorités très proche ça ça a été
découvert en 2006 juan équipe
internationale de physiciens de
linguistes et d'informaticiens d'un côté
des linguistes pense que à l'origine
tous les hommes du monde parlaient la
même langue on appelle ça la mono genèse
de la langue mais d'autres linguiste
pense que les langues sont apparus en
fonction des besoins de chaque groupe
d'êtres humains sur terre jean-marie
lambert le professeur de linguistique à
l'université lumière lyon ii explique
que pour organiser leur périple à
travers l'australie il ya plus de
cinquante mille ans les homo sapiens du
sud est asiatique avait nécessairement
développer un langage sophistiqué et
complexe mais certains de leurs
homologues qui vivaient sur d'autres
continents à la même époque et dont les
besoins étaient très basique en fait les
bd seule préoccupation c'était de se
nourrir et faire des enfants pour
assurer la survie il avait aucune raison
de développer un langage aussi complexe
et si on y pense à l'époque il ya à
peine un million d'êtres humains sur
terre soit en gros une vie comme
marseille répartis sur toute la surface
du globe d'ailleurs ça me fait penser
que je viens jouer à marseille avec mon
spectacle en création le 17 juin
n'attendez pas que ce soit remplie le
lien est en descriptions c'était petites
salles bref avec si peu d'êtres humains
sur la terre peu de chances qu'ils se
rencontrent assez pour développer une
langue commune passant la deuxième des
astuces pour apprendre une langue une
fois qu'on connaît sa motivation il faut
aller directement vers le plus utile
c'est ça mon conseil oubliez la
précision laisser tomber les cris passer
à côté de ce que on vous dit être
important l'important c'est en fonction
de votre motivation de votre besoin vous
n'allez pas à prendre les mêmes choses
en fonction de vous voulez partir en
voyage ou si vous voulez faire un
spectacle ou si vous voulez aller dans
un congrès haitink donc dites vous bien
une chose les autres ils s'en balancent
des erreurs que vous allez faire
l'important c'est d'arriver à faire
comprendre sa pensée et de comprendre au
global celle des autres la perfection ça
marche aussi dans votre compréhension
vous allez pas tout comprendre pas
chaque mot d'une phrase qu'on vous dit
et ça c'est pas un problème en fait si
vous comprenez l'intention on va dire le
sujet principal au message de base alors
c'est ok essayer des trucs mois une de
mes patients par exemple c'est de parler
avec les serveurs et les chauffeurs de
taxi pour blablater de tout et de rien
sur le trajet ça c'est un bon moyen
d'échanger avec des personnes d'essayer
de faire des blagues pour avoir un vrai
moment convivial et ça c'est pas
académique mais franchement être capable
de nouer un contact amical rapidement je
vous jure c'est le plus utile d'ailleurs
c'est pas utile de vouloir parler toutes
les langues du monde absolument déjà y
en a trop et puis beaucoup de pays
pratiquent plusieurs langues au
luxembourg ces trois à quatre langues et
je vous parle même pas de l'afrique du
sud qui compte onze langues officielles
il existe même des langues qui se
sifflent te fais un délire il ya une
soixantaine de langues qui sont sifflés
qui sont répertoriées dans le monde dont
le six bons numéros
sur l'île de gomera aux canaries qui est
inscrite depuis 2009 au patrimoine
culturel immatériel de l'humanité
tellement c'est stylé où on estime que
le maximum de langues peu parlées un
être humain ces bilans au dessus de 6
langues on parle même plus de poliglote
mehdi père polyglotte des linguistes
estiment qu'il faut une année
d'apprentissage assidu pour maîtriser
pleinement les bases justes les bases
d'une langue et c'est ça qu'on veut des
bases pratiques débat utile après il est
toujours temps d'affiner le vocabulaire
et la syntaxe pour s'améliorer mais
juste lui avoir une bonne base et c'est
ça qui m'amène à la troisième astuces la
troisième astuce c'est qu'il faut que
vous favoriser l'apprentissage à l'oral
à 99% ouais c'est presque 100% moi ma
vie personnelle m'emmener à travailler à
l'étranger jusqu'en 2011 et je faisais
parfois jusqu'à 30 pays part en
différents en une seule année vous alors
que j'étais moi une quiche en anglais et
en espagnol à l'école les langues c'est
une catastrophe alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour moi et bien le premier
contrat que j'ai accepté en fait c'était
en inde et je parlais pas du tout un mot
d'anglais et j'avais six mois pour
réussir à parler sur place avec nos
clients et pour leur faire une
conférence sur la mémoire qui durera à
peu près 30 millions donc j'ai signé le
contrat je parlais pas anglais et là je
pense que vous comprenez un peu mieux
les deux premières astuces que je vous
ai donné maintenant elles sont issues de
l'hyper sauf bref j'ai développé un
réseau qui m'a emmené ensuite dans le
monde entier avant de poser mes valises
à paris et tenter l'aventuré du
spectacle au théâtre il ya maintenant
pratiquement 12 ans 11 ans quand je
parle de l'oral c'est que dans le fond
ils nous apprenons une langue pour
discuter avec des gens dire c'est
basique pour comprendre qu'on nous parle
et pour nous exprimer ce que j'ai pu
constater par mon expérience et qu'il
fallait un peu assumer le côté
j'apprendrai l'écrit plus tard et puis
tant pis quoi et pour ça le mieux c'est
l'immersion aura alors trois exemples
que je pratique pour apprendre quand je
me promène je commande tout ce que je
vois tout ce que je fais tout ce que je
pense dans la langue que j'apprends et
comme souvent j'ai pas tous les maux
mais j'essaie quand même de le faire de
trouver une astuce pour comme s'il
devait me faire comprendre en fait je
parle un ami imaginaire tout le temps
voilà mais essayer de faire ça dans la
rue c'est hyper je le fais en plus en
chuchotant pour essayer de pratiquer
donc c'est hyper chelou mais ça fait
vite progresser ensuite même si je
travaille pas encore les cris la lecture
je me procure des livres dans la langue
que je veux parler mais je me procure en
même temps que se livrent la version
audio du livre et je lis en même temps
que j'écoute la version audio est ce
assez pour comprendre les sons pour les
reconnaître pour habituer mon oreille en
fait et je vais même plus loin de ça je
me mets en immersion de plusieurs
langues en même temps et ça c'est très
intéressant voici pourquoi il existe un
phénomène psychologique que les
scientifiques appellent l'émergence de
la conscience métalinguistique ça fait
peur mais c'est très simple c'est une
sorte de capacités du cerveau qui fait
que plus on connaît deux langues plus il
est facile pour le cerveau d'en
apprendre une nouvelle alors évidemment
c'est plus simple de développer ça avant
l'âge de quatre ans puisque c'est sur
cette période qu'on possède une capacité
d'apprentissage améliorée quand on est
adulte c'est donc moins rapide mais ce
qu on précise que très rarement c'est
qu'un enfant va oublier très vite les
langues si les pratiques pas
régulièrement quasi quotidiennement
alors qu'un adulte il va les encres et
beaucoup plus longtemps et beaucoup plus
facilement enfant on apprend à parler
tout court et ça c'est déjà une nouvelle
langue et pour appuyer cette troisième
astuces vous remarquerez que ça se passe
principalement à l'oral d'ailleurs
revenons-en à la phrase du départ
pourquoi dans plus d'un millier de
langues à travers le monde les
appellations de père d'une papa et mer
ou maman contiennent une consonne labial
donc c'est le paie le bem et le fc à
cause du biberon et de la péter en
général tous les bébés du monde tête et
ont donc la même activité musculaire des
lèvres et de la bouche donc il développe
les mêmes premier mouvement des lèvres
et c'est ça qui explique que les
premiers mots qu'ils arrivent à
prononcer se ressemblent autant et pour
finir vous donne une astuce quand même
en bonus dans votre cerveau il ya un mec
il est tapi dans l'ombre il s'appelle
michel et michel il se trouve dans les
amygdales et quand tu dois parler dans
une autre langue michel te dit elle fait
pas ils vont se moquer tu vas trompés
ils vont pas de comprendre et un de
trucs un peu désagréable comme ça ils te
fais avoir peur de pas être à la hauteur
mais spoiler qu'on apprend une langue on
la télécharge pas dans son cerveau en
fait on est mauvais l'apprentissage
c'est forcément faire des erreurs et
s'améliorait mais michel c'est un mytho
et j'en ai la preuve qu un étranger vous
parle et qui maîtrisent pas bien le
français l'accent où la structure est ce
que vous jugez est-ce que vous moquer de
lui méchamment non la majorité d'entre
nous vous prenez le temps et même
spontanément vous lui répondez un peu
plus lentement avec des mots que vous
savez plus simple alors rassurez vous
c'est pareil pour vous quand vous
discutez avec d'autres personnes dans
une autre langue donc donner un truc à
michel pour qu'ils s'occupent et vous
l'écoutez plus mieux que ça prenait
l'engagement pour six mois d'avancé à
votre rythme sur une langue celle que
vous et en utilisant ses astuces
dites-moi laquelle vous allez choisir
comme langue ça peut être sympa si c'est
votre première nouvelle langue ou pas
d'ailleurs motivé vous les uns les
autres sa phrase ça fera bien faire
taire les michel vous pouvez même vous
donner rendez vous dans les commentaires
pour faire des sessions discussion
ensemble pourquoi pas et puis si vous
voulez vous pouvez vous améliorer en
utilisant le sponsor du jour à savoir
babel que je remercie encore de bach
sponsorisé cette vidéo s'il a pris vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas de passer par le
lien dans la description pour avoir une
grosse réduction spéciale de 30 % quant
à moi je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard ici je vous mets le dernier
match des regrets sur la mémoire obstrat
liquide pour apprendre une langue
surtout la première des expériences ici
notre vidéo sur l'apprentissage des
langues que j'avais fait un peu plus
longtemps vous pouvez vous abonner si
vous voulez et puis moi je vous dis à
bientôt soit ici soit dans une salle de
spectacle encore en tournée vous avez le
temps on est en création qui doit
s'afficher un peu partout autour de moi
prenez bien soin de vous à très bientôt
ciao